journée d'information pour cette
trentaine de femmes en recherche
d'emploi dans le cadre de son programme
de mixité professionnelle pour l'emploi
leur propose de découvrir le métier de
conductrice de bus base de la mixité
professionnelle c'est aujourd'hui
orientée des femmes sur des métiers
d'hommes ou des hommes sur des métiers
de femmes c'est trouver justement cette
fameuse parité sur certains secteurs qui
sont en difficulté et amener des
compétences vers des métiers justement
qui en ont besoin
je présente à ce qu on vous laisse vous
représentez les plus intéressés ont
ensuite pu participer un job dating avec
les quatre entreprises partenaires seize
d'entre elles seront retenues après
validation de leur motivation par un
test théorique et pratique suivie de
trois jours d'insertion professionnelle
au sein des entreprises
elles bénéficieront de trois mois de
formation financée par pôle emploi et
ses partenaires vous rendez compte j'ai
45 ans j'en ai encore pour 25 ans de
travail c'est à dire qu'une fois que je
signe c'est jusqu'à la retraite
et j'aurais pas de souci de chercher du
boulot ailleurs ou de crise parce que
dans le transport il ya toujours du
travail donc c'est vraiment
on comptera sur quoi une aubaine pour
les quatre entreprises présentes le
transport est actuellement au manque de
conducteurs et conductrices
c'est un vivier intéressant ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de retrouver des gens
qu'ils soient motivés par ce métier là
la découverte de ce métier là la
valorisation de ce métier et la mixité
est quelque chose d'hyper important
c'est une politique d'entreprise
donc on a espoir de trouver des gens
motivés intéressant objectif pour cette
entreprise embauche et ces femmes à la
sortie de leur formation
généralement en cdi pour 1800 euros
bruts sur un contrat de 35 heures